[Music]
[Laughter]
scoop down a quick scoop they're happy
when they follow man gravity's a [ __ ]
to do it submitted by Lloyd from
Entourage a Republican candidate for
sheriff preemptively released a photo of
himself in blackface what Oh cuz he's
like I want to do it before anyone else
catches me doing it it's actually
probably a good idea Kurian here's all
my dirty laundry isn't it better to just
hire like a private investigator and
have them bury all that [ __ ] like the
truth will set you free
Bart it's like an eighth mile at the end
if you haven't seen it yet turn this off
but then come back but Eminem you know
says all of his things that the other
guy's gonna say about him and then the
other guy chokes cuz he doesn't have
anything to say [ __ ] wait Candy's no
baby
oh he says dude
he's really good at the famous rap
that's new is he a new rapper the
up-and-coming she's awake
yes mom spaghetti on his sweater already
all right so this Republican sheriff
candidate in South Carolina is trying to
own up to his mistakes right so that's
how he actually kicked off his whole
campaign with this Facebook yeah
everyone's probably like [ __ ] we have
nothing on him now what can you say
about it because usually the other
campaigns like did you know he actually
starves children unless people can't
forgive him yeah yeah so he so here's
the thing I want to tell you at the
start of my campaign some things that
politicians would try to hide things my
opponents may use may try to use to
tarnish my integrity
but it
didn't work out in his favor uh-huh I
mean that's a hard one
I'm gonna share well I'll tell you why
after but first I'll share with you a
little clip of when he talks about cuz
he ends up saying like he got tickets
he's been divorced and remain remarried
and like all these other things right
but this part he's a new speech writer I
think I will show you divorce I did
blackface I got tickets actually didn't
even call it like you have a drinking
problem
[Applause]
blackface what do you say I just I'll
show you the costume so and about ten
years ago there's a young police officer
is that how he talks Carolina I attended
a law enforcement Halloween party
dressed as ruthless trouble lifted big
Meech Flannery anything that was a
different time today we understand that
type of costume is troubling to many to
those who may just want you guys to hear
how you're saying it those okay so I'm
opening my campaign with transparency
that's why you can always tell me to
tell you the truth that's the
cornerstone of trust tiny and this
[ __ ] chair look at that chair why did
it get the biggest how do you literally
Betty looks like a cookie
it was like he's at the toddler table
how did he get it to look like that
oh honey thing is way that his
girlfriend I don't know what it is but
it's really another white person no in
the video they didn't blur her face out
I know but the photo I have is it's
blurred out yeah here's the thing he the
way his language that he's using makes
me be like you're asking me politician
because he's not saying I did blackface
I [ __ ] up I learned when this is wrong
I'm a better person to try to go around
it these were different times that's try
use wait so what do you say he's a he's
a kingpin he was a drug kingpin for
something so he's saying that he dressed
up as a drug kingpin but the whole thing
here though is or a notorious drug
trafficker go hold the reason why this
oh it's not even up anymore yeah well we
take it down from his Facebook but the
reason why there were so much backlash
is because not once did he ever
apologize he never this is what people
are saying that he didn't even address
the racism behind doing that y'all know
why it's harmful over the baby yeah yeah
he just sounds like I understand why
this may be harmful not saying like I
apologize and that's the thing that
really rub you and then like this one
comment says if my grandparents knew in
the 50s that wasn't a good look there's
no excuse for you not to know in 2009
with all the best internet they didn't
know that's the whole thing right the
funny thing is it looks like a party
with the ton of black people there I
just see one okay for some reason in the
video I thought there were black people
in the background but it's it's it's
white people maybe that's a black bag it
was my face yeah my mind filled it up
because his his date to the party or
whoever she was I thought he was like
like a hip-hop black club they're all
hanging out and that he was like the
Tanner might need a lot of [ __ ]
filling in the blank right yeah I
thought he was a token white guy like
the the mm of the groove between d12 you
know what I mean like so yeah filled in
the blanks there
of saying or someone else commented
there is a difference between announcing
just so your political opponents don't
out you and apologizing for having the
wrong beliefs in the past you know what
else this should be announcing so you
guys need to be subscribing right now
you know it's funny like that's what
happens when you don't have any clearly
don't have any people of color on your
staff like that was probably some white
kid being like we should air out your
laundry so you don't get cancelled - and
he's like you're right let me write this
speech up and then no one checks it it's
so funny cuz it's low-budget and local
and so the way that it's done by the way
for a local commercial that was like
film pretty well all the commercials are
like a Trump commercial came on TV the
other day and it was done like that -
that's what I quality for a local for a
local cop but it's just hilarious
because the rioting and [ __ ] is all bad
you know you picked that one picture
where he's posing with a black woman to
be like see ya it was finally this all
about that because if it was him with a
bunch of white people people would have
been coming with pitchforks mmm
to be like find her ask her what she
thinks Rachel's cool with it
um there was like what what Prince was
it that was dressed as like Hitler at a
Friday yeah there was like one of those
Henry about orange haired one yeah yeah
Prince the one I just got married -
Mangin mark Harry Harry wait do you guys
feel that ten years is a long time yeah
because I'm not peeking
cuz yeah when I think about ten years
I'm like I don't even think he should
have to preemptively come out and if
people do come out with it it's like
times do change like it kind of sucks
that people have to come out instead of
actually like vote for me because this
is what I believe in it seems like the
trend now is vote for me because I'm not
like this anymore no so he was saying
the rest of the ad here saying like vote
for me because I believe in honesty and
being upfront and so this is why I'm
showing you my dirty laundry right now
cuz that when I like if you vote for me
to become sheriff like you can know that
I will be
honest with you and be completely
transparent so he is tying it back to
his campaign so this is interesting
because you think about like the Kevin
Hart situation right it's like there's
so many things right now that's like oh
you're gay in high school right like I'm
guilty of that I'm [ __ ] queer like I
was saying that because that's you're
not thinking you're not in an
environment where you're seeing people
that are like that it wasn't as safe to
be out like yeah there's got to be a
limit of like what do you call it like
statute of limitations like like yeah
for after committing a crime right
especially age right like I think he's
got less leeway cuz he's an adult and
should know better in that situation but
when you're in your teens and your brain
is and although I said story with the
bush beer the guy that he ends up
raising all this money because he wanted
some beer fun but then all over yeah and
then it ended up going to Children's
Hospital but then that reporter comes
out and says well did you know he
tweeted us a really dumb [ __ ] back when
he was 16 and then all the back line I
understand that one but I guess for the
politician like I like that was kind of
a big thing for me because I wouldn't
want to want to vote for someone that's
racist and since I don't know his
history now know his story if that does
come up I'm like wow we should talk
about that comes up with a date I'm like
oh that's ten years ago yeah I don't
know like when it comes to racism today
I think that no matter what it could be
60 years ago people are getting Bob left
and right because there was that other
politician to that that like took a
photo with the Klansmen or something
Justin Trudeau like America's Sweetheart
of Canada did I did blackface in it just
came out and it was like a story for 24
hours and I got swept it on the road
yeah because this guy's making a
decision for hundreds and thousands of
people you know what I mean so like I
feel like this should be a conversation
but I also but I also feel like instead
of being defensive about it
we're like if it was run for me I'm
Sheriff because I've done this and if
his resume shows that he is accepting
and he supports diversity and all the
stuff that he dies on yeah yeah I think
that should be the focus don't come out
defensive and I don't think that we
should even as a community I think we
should focus on that and you don't have
receipts to back up how you change
I think you're right it's like maybe a
person who was able to change their mind
and get out of their comfort zone and be
like oh you know what I do need to
understand black lives matter I do need
to understand like how people are other
dinh my town and like look what I've
done
politically to help it's like but you
can you to be his writer there's a
picture of me doing blackface I was a
drug kingpin now I got a baby it's like
there's no connection but if you did I
[ __ ] up here but I've spent this many
years policing the black community and I
did this and I did that and like I do
community service yeah no receipt that's
like that's very different yeah well he
did talk about his like career but yeah
he didn't talk about like he thought he
was doing something look at everything
like you guys I've got it these others
whose groundbreaking an honest
politician look at me go they got it
vote binder in the bathroom cause he's
not we're not left with the result it's
almost like I used to be a part of the
Klan now I have a baby and I'll be I'll
be honest with you and it's like so
still a part of the Claire like what
else is there going on bro like do you
still hang out with them well I mean
there were a lot of support and his
thing too but obviously way more
backlash because now he took it down but
there were people saying like you got my
vote oh my god kinda races now it's just
like most of America it's like I'm cool
with black I'm cool that I have black
friends but like that's about as far as
I'll take it in his defense though can
we see that what the drug trafficker it
looks like maybe he did a really good
job I think he was just going as generic
drug trafficker no he did name-o he
didn't need a mitri demetrius big Meech
Flenory can we look him up because what
if they were like you look like the
white version of him
and then like if you just had like a
darker school buddy they look exactly
the same then I think that's the problem
is people don't know like inside jokes
and things can go outside mmm so so
should we not take pictures anymore
don't talk in his [ __ ] you know we're
gonna because to me if he looks just
like the bad guy and if his friends did
tell him you should do it then to me I'm
just like this guy's a really good sense
of humor I don't see it as being raised
that's not like when what's-his-face for
all for now please no no Fred what's his
name Armisen Armisen yeah when he plays
Obama look like you or some look like
him the capacity of that it's from
Twitter
[Music]